- I KNOW.
THE ONE DAY WE NEED TO FOCUS,
AND SHE HAD TO TEMP.
- [Australian accent]
DON'T MIND ME.
I'LL JUST BE HERE
WITH MY BREASTS AND BOOBS,
BEING A GIRL
AS HARD AS POSSIBLE.
- FREAKIN' AUSTRIANS,
LIKE, LAND DOWN UNDER.
- AND YOU KNOW SHE JUST DATES
THE HOTTEST DUDES OF ALL TIME.
- IF YOU DON'T WANT TO DATE ME,
THAT'S FINE. I GET THAT.
BUT YOU'RE WRONG,
AND I HATE YOU.
- LET HER DATE THE--
THE UNDERWEAR MODELS
AND THE PRO SURFERS, OKAY?
I'M SORRY
IF WE'RE REAL PEOPLE.
- WE'RE REAL.
- SO REAL.
- WE'RE THE REALEST PEOPLE.
- I KNOW.
- SO REAL.
- I'M SICK OF
BEAUTIFUL PEOPLE
WHO DON'T HAVE TO WORK
FOR THEIR BEAUTY,
WHEN I'M OVER HERE,
SWEATIN' MY BALLS OFF
FOR ALL THIS BEAUTY.
AND YOU CAN HARDLY TELL
SOME DAYS.
- OH, NO.
I'M NOT WEARING UNDERWEAR.
- MM.
- WHAT HAPPENS
WHEN I PRE-EJACULATE?
- NO ONE IS GOING TO PRE-,
OKAY?
- I ALWAYS DO.
- GUYS! LET'S--
LET'S JUST THINK OF A FLAW,
RIGHT? SHE'S NOT PERFECT.
YES, SHE'S EXACTLY WHAT
WE WANT TO BE RAPED BY, RIGHT?
- MM-HMM.
- YEAH.
- BUT DOES SHE
HAVE THE BUILD
TO BIRTH ME
MY OLYMPIC TRIATHLETE SON?
NO. NOT WITH THOSE GIANT CANS
AND TAPERED WAIST.
I'M SORRY.
IT'S JUST NOT GONNA HAPPEN.
- DERS, SHE HAS THE FACE
OF A GOD.
IF I LOOK DIRECTLY AT HER,
I WILL PRE- MY PANTS.
- YOU PRE- A LOT TOO.